>> Laura: IT'S TIME FOR OUR SEEN
AND UNSEEN SEGMENT WHERE WE
EXPLORE THE CUL TRULY SIDE OF OF
THE MIDTERM CAMPAIGN AND FOR
THAT WE TURN TO THE AUTHOR OF
THE WISEMEN WHO FOUND CHRISTMAS.
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR RAYMOND
ARROYO.
THE DEMOCRATS ARE GOING INTO THE
MIDTERMS LEANING INTO ONE BIG
ISSUE.
WHAT IS IT?
>> IT'S ABORTION FOR SOME
REASON.
>> Laura: STILL?
>> EVEN THOUGH THE SUPREME COURT
RETURNED THE ISSUE TO THE STATES
DEMOCRATS HAVE BEEN TRYING TO
TURN THIS INTO A NATIONAL
CONCERN.
THOUGH WHEN JOHN FETTERMAN
SOUNDS OFF ON ABORTION LAURA I
THINK HE MIGHT BE TRYING TO HAVE
IT BOTH WAYS.
>> I RUN ON ROE V WADE.
I CELEBRATE THE DEMISE OF ROE V
WADE.
>> I'D LIKE TO SPIN THE WHEEL
PAT.
>> Laura: WHAT IS HE DOING.
>> WHAT IS HE TRYING TO SAY
LAURA.
>> Laura: WHY IS DOING THIS?
>> THEY'RE DOING THIS BECAUSE
THEY THINK IT IS AN IMPORTANT
WEDGE ISSUE AND CAN WIN VOTES
AND TO UNDERSCORE JUST HOW
IMPORTANT DEMOCRATS CONSIDER
ABORTION VICE-PRESIDENT KAMALA
HARRIS RETURNED TO HOWARD
UNIVERSITY FOR A BET SPECIAL
WITH BLACK VOTERS TONIGHT.
>> ONE DOES NOT NEED TO ABANDON
THEIR FAITH OR DEEPLY HELD
BELIEFS TO AGREE THE GOVERNMENT
SHOULD NOT BE TELLING HER WHAT
TO DO WITH HER BODY.
WHEN PEOPLE START COMING FOR --
AT SOMEONE TO TAKE AWAY THEIR
RIGHTS, WE'RE ALL VULNERABLE.
IT WILL JUST BE A MINUTE BEFORE
THEY COME FOR SOME OF YOUR
RIGHTS.
SO LET'S NOT LET THIS TRAIN
LEAVE THE STATION.
>> LAURA IT WAS ALL ABORTION
FROM BEGINNING TO END.
>> Laura: OH, MY GOD.
>> THIS IS THE BEST THING SHE
HAS TO OFFER THE
AFRICAN-AMERICAN COMMUNITY.
HOWEVER, WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
PURE RESEARCH, 81% OF BLACK
AMERICANS CONSIDER VIOLENT CRIME
THE NUMBER ONE ISSUE THEY'RE
FOCUSED ON.
76% IN A POLL FOUND THAT THEIR
TOP CONCERN WAS INFLATION.
THIS IS NOT EVEN IN THE TOP
FIVE.
BUT HERE SHE WAS PRIME TIME, ONE
HOUR, DEVOTED TO ABORTION.
AND S AND L APPARENTLY ALSO GOT
THE MEMO.
THEY ABANDONED LAUGHS THIS
WEEKEND TO PUSH THIS ABORTION
PSA.
>> GAS PRICES ARE UP AND
FAMILIES ARE REALLY HURTING BUT
THAT'S NOT GOING TO MAGICALLY
DISAPPEAR NO MATTER WHO YOU VOTE
FOR BUT WHAT WILL KEEP
DISAPPEARING IS SAFE ACCESS TO
A, WOULD.
I HOPE TO HELL EVERYONE VOTES
BECAUSE, REMEMBER, WE ALL LOVE
SOMEONE WHO'S HAD AN ABORTION.
>> Laura: OH, MY GOD, IT'S SO
UNFUNNY, A A DEGREESIVELY UNIF
YOUY.
THEY DID DO A FUNNY COVID SKIT.
>> SHE TALKS ABOUT THINGS
DISAPPEARING, WHAT'S
DISAPPEARING IS THE AUDIENCE
BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT TELLING
JOKES.
THIS ABOUT AS ENTERTAINING AS
THAT NPR AUDIO ABORTION THEY
PLAYED THE OTHER DAY, LAURA.
I DON'T KNOW WHY THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY HAS DECIDED THIS IS GOING
TO BE THEIR DELIVERANCE.
THIS IS THEIR WEDGE ISSUE.
IT DOESN'T WORK.
BUT MY FAVORITE TACTIC FROM SOME
OF THESE POLITICIANS IS WHEN
CONFRONTED WITH REAL QUESTIONS,
THEY JUST REVERT TO THE OLD,
WHAT?
OH, HUH?
DO YOU HEAR ANY -- I DON'T HEAR
ANYTHING.
CAN YOU HEAR SOMETHING?
I DON'T.
>> SEE YOUR HANDLING OF THE
PANDEMIC.
WE ALL KNOW THE CRITICS OVER THE
PAST FEW YEARS.
DO YOU HAVE ANY REGRETS AND --
>> I'M SORRY.
[BLEEP].
>> GO AHEAD GOVERNOR.
CAN YOU HEAR ME OKAY?
YOU GOT ME GOVERNOR?
>> DID I DO THAT WHEN I TOUCHED
THE EAR THING?
IT WAS STARTING TO FALL OUT.
>> OH, NO, IT'S OKAY.
>> CAN'T HEAR YOU WATER RUNNING.
REMEMBER THAT OLD -- IT'S THE
SAME THING.
>> CONVENIENTLY WHISPERS AUDIO
GOT LOCKED DOWN SO IT WAS
PERFECT TIMING.
>> WHEN I TOUCHED IT IT WAS
FALLING OUT.
PUT IT BACK IN SWEETHEART.
IS IT SO HARD TO FIGURE THAT
OUT.
>> EXACTLY.
SHE HAD ENOUGH TO CURSE ON AIR
BUT COULDN'T RESPOND TO THE
QUESTION ABOUT HER LOCKDOWN.
THIS IS LIKE THE WHITE HOUSE
PRESS SECRETARY TRYING TO SPIN
BIDEN'S VOW TO CLOSE ALL POLL
PLANTS LAURA A GREAT CLOSING
ARGUMENT IN PENNSYLVANIA, BY THE
WAY, HERE'S HOW THE PRESS
SECRETARY EXPLAINED THINGS.
>> IT WAS LOUD AND HARD TO HEAR,
I THINK, OR MAYBE NOT, EXACTLY
WHAT, WHAT WAS BEING SAID.
THE PRESIDENT'S WORDS WE BELIEVE
WERE TWISTED.
>> HIS WORDS WERE TWISTED.
THAT ARGUMENT IS WHAT'S TWISTED.
A THIRD OF OUR COAL PLANTS,
LAURA, ARE ALREADY CLOSED.
HOW ARE WE GOING TO POWER OUR
ELECTRICAL GRID BUILDING ALL
THESE STATIONS.
>> Laura: WE TALKED ABOUT IT ON
THE ANGLE THEY WANT TO GET RID
OF DRILLING, COAL, THEY HATE
CARS, THEY HATE FRACKING SO THAT
LEAVES US WITH THE GAS BAGS IN
WASHINGTON POWERING THE WHOLE
COUNTRY.
THAT'S IT.
>> LAURA, JUST SO YOU KNOW AND
I'M GOING TO LEAVE YOU WITH
THIS, THE PRESIDENT IS CLOSING
THIS ENTIRE MIDTERM SEASON BY
DISPLAYING THE CAN I HAVE
LEADERSHIP TONIGHT THAT YOU'D
EXPECT, CONFIDENT, STEADY.
>> TWO, TEN, 12, 15, WHOOPS,
STEPPING ON A -- THERE'S A --
THAT'S BLACK.
ANYWAY.
WE'RE GOING TO CODIFY ROE V WADE
IN JANUARY AND MAKE IT THE RULE
OF THE LAND.
>> JILL IS ALWAYS THERE POINTING
THE WAY, LAURA.
THEY NEVER SEND HIM TO AN EVENT
WOUND A MINDER, OBAMA, JILL.
BUT I LOVE THE MOMENT WHERE HE
[MOBILS] IN THE CLOSING
ARGUMENT.
AT THAT WORKED WELL.
>> Lau